[Music]
okay
perfect
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up guys my name is Thomas
dobiziola whatever you want to call me
this is the dope as usual podcast I'm
here with my co-host Marty O'Neal what's
up guys what the hell
what's up guys today is adobe's usual
podcast you guys asked for this next
guest
every four seconds that I'm on Tick Tock
I get a notification about it every time
I get on Twitch I get the same
notification and Twitter now so thank
you guys so much please introduce my
next guest uh streamer non-stop what I
like to call Professional potheads all
right you get smoke weed for for your
career
hell yeah so this is the Chris you
dollar episode thank you so much for
being here man thank you for having me
thank you and your first interview you
said yeah first time let's go oh my God
I love being the place where it happens
yeah just like the most disarming place
ever you want to smoke weed and laugh
all right this camera is by the way yeah
that's pretty much it so right down to
it because a lot of people
um that maybe they don't follow your
stuff are gonna go oh we you know we
take okay we because you can't smoke
weed on Tick Tock but you have found a
way I haven't that's the thing I did for
like five six months but it's not like
that no more I don't know what happened
well you I see you with smoke I mean I
think anyone can get away with oh you're
not exhaling but if I show weed anymore
it's gone oh it was a cool six month
period where like Seth Rogen posted
a joint yeah so we posted that and I
just do edited it and said like why
can't he do that but none of us can so I
started like pushing the limits I've had
videos deleted over the past two years
for like showing bowls and bongs but I
started showing joints and for some
reason they loved that Tick Tock was
like whatever
yeah I had rolling tutorials I was
showing myself like take bong rips
grinding stuff up and then I moved out
to Arizona where weed was legal after
living in an illegal state for so long
I'm so excited to smoke legally they
start deleting everything like
I haven't shown weed since I got out
here
oh yeah oh that was such a question I
had like that what how do you do it so
how many times really they're like bro
we're gonna delete your account stop
posting this WeChat I get a deleted
video probably every other video I post
oh [__] like I'll repost it I'll I'll
just go back and forth I'm not afraid of
having my account deleted because I feel
like they would have deleted it by now
yeah they already did one time I got it
back in like two days oh with Tick Tock
yeah oh do they I said the word weed a
few times there yeah done it's weird I
people say they pick favorites I think
they do a little bit but I've also had
like 400 violations like most of my
account is gone most of my videos I've
ever made are just not there oh so what
you're doing is bringing in so much
traffic like keep him here but don't let
him do what he wants yeah they'll ban me
for seven days at a time oh [__] you put
on timeout yeah a lot I've never even
gotten that far I've never dude as soon
as I said a weed a few times they're
like yo eat a dick get off this yeah
yeah and then I'll do that well you know
what I couldn't post for a couple days
yeah it wouldn't let me upload that's
what that's what they hit me okay or
comment I've never had the comment one
yeah they did that to me people who said
like
yes and then they can't comment for a
week it's a funny platform I don't know
man it's not the place for me it's not
the place for you no I love Tick Tock
because I just get on there and go oh
Vine all right you like this now with
shorts going monetized do you feel like
maybe and that's just like we all got
the email for that like yesterday
do you feel like that's gonna
incentivize you in the new year to lean
more into that versus Tick Tock content
do you think like weed content over
there is still going to be monetizable
because I just got into YouTube like
this year this is my first time really
like putting effort into it and I have
one monetized video out of like the
seven I've made and so I don't know like
if Shorts aren't moved I'll do it but I
I just I'm not sure yet
yeah I'm not positive because I just got
monetized on YouTube for the first like
I don't I I don't I'm not monetized
until what a month and a half ago I was
a goddamn historic moment yeah like a
month and a half ago they're like yo
here and I couldn't believe it but
I want to say thank you I won't say
which videos but some weed videos are
monetized don't know how hope it stays
that way yeah I have one video where
like my YouTube videos aren't really
focused on weed they're more focused on
like another thing with weed on the side
yeah I watched some and you have
gameplay yeah yeah yeah like I have one
video where I was playing a game and
smoking on the side that one's monetized
but then I have another video where I
smoked less and played a game and that
one's not and it's not monetized yeah so
uh you know what man I think it's really
all about how they feel that day it's
got a if you got a human review because
you if you gotten those yeah human
review and told you [__] off yeah I get
that a lot dude but so
tick tock
when did you realize that you can
actually start gaining a following on
there I mean obviously you saw some
followers grow but I think it's more
about the comments oh no keep that
working oh thanks there you go I think I
kind of cheated if I'm being honest wow
um
I started Tick Tock with 25 000
followers right wow my roommate had an
account he was doing some like
corny [__] he was on there like showing
off his abs and stuff and at one point
he was like I don't want this I don't
want to be associated with it so oh you
embarrassed himself out of this
but like he offered me the account I was
like oh for sure and I start posting
some like jokes I instantly lose like
six ten thousand of the followers right
away but um
I made one video where I like
I made uh me on my Wii do you know like
wheeze had like those characters you
could make and they had one where you
could use like
um your camera and it would make the me
from that and I made the me a white
woman with like orange hair instead of
what I look like and that video got like
10 million views that's all I gotta do
so is the ab content that was like you
know what app we we like this not the
jokes yeah that'd be kind of odd
starting with like all right what's this
fan base like abs for sure
what next how do I transfer this because
I'm sure you've been following on
Instagram I don't follow this human
being why are they where are my feed
yeah and then you go and go oh someone's
sold the guy's count because I don't
follow this that was very heavy on
Instagram when I first started yeah back
in the day people used to sell accounts
so so often the um first time I ever
heard of that this was 2014 or 15.
and my homie I I don't know if it wants
to say but my homie used to run a big
weed account
and I remember this is when we're all
just like trying still like trying to
start and you can move that towards you
too
um
he got somebody gave him 100 Bands for
his account a hundred thousand real
dollars and I remember thinking for your
Instagram account how many followers oh
two hundred thousand
this is when Instagram just started
though 200 000 met 200 real thousand
people following every day all day
and I remember the day he got the check
and I'm like are you kidding there's
money in accounts and then people
started hacking accounts and selling
them yeah I don't know if you've ever
been around since that but that was
terrible I remember there was a time
where people were like just going on
following sprees because everyone back
in the day if you fall back they follow
back right and then you unfollow
everyone everybody might do that ten
thousand followers I remember that man I
genuinely like following the fans of the
podcast it's like no no I'm really
following you I'm all watching your
stories and [__] I've done it before
with a few people and a few people just
like God they just made me feel like bro
chill out not like
I don't like your content more of like
dude
you know I don't want to put them on
blast too hard it was more of like a
yo give me like a half an armful to spay
like give me just like let me read my
error yeah like a little bit I like
interacting with people but that doesn't
mean like we're boys I mean we could be
fresh but it's like bro you no you can't
sleep in my house because I don't know
you and I have a person with me that I
would like to keep safe I don't know you
you could be nice I've had multiple
people
and people ask to live with you
all the time
y'all clean and do everything while you
do your [__] and you know with smoking
I'm like bro I am not dating you that
doesn't work for me man I'm sorry that's
so funny but it's more like damn it's
like some cable guys I really think did
you really think I was gonna be like bro
it's a great idea what's your name
what's nice to meet you moving
[__] like that I don't know but for tick
tock I'm sure because Tick Tock is
the newest app and the most viewed I
feel I feel like people are on that
heavy bro constantly like the comment
sections say on your you know what I
mean versus Instagram like oh 10 000
likes on the comment like dude Instagram
doesn't even go hard like that is it
real or is it tick tock wanting to have
you tell me how do you feel about that
it seems real I think Tick Tock comments
is one of the worst places on Earth
though like after after being a creator
for this long dude people down there
like I mean I've made some content that
I understand why people get mad at me
and [__] but like like in what way I
mean I said cracker one time and people
didn't like that
so did Richard Pryor a lot all right so
that's funny that's funny but I get it
some people will get offended
your honky's the best word of all time
honky lips
hunky lips is always the best one
because from fat uh from uh
um National Lampoon's Vacation
and he goes through St Louis asks for
directions and the guys are stealing his
hubcaps as he's asking for directions
they spray paint honky lip scrubs
hilarious Michael Jones call people
hunky lips all the time I'm still on
that shows
I've been needing new insults
so I'm sorry
you're doing tick tock
is there a community I don't follow I'm
not in Tick Tock is there like a weak
Community there there's a weed Community
it's it's pretty angry compared to like
other platforms Tick Tock is just a
hostile platform I don't expect it I
didn't I thought the opposite I only
like positivity things okay so when I
get on my feet it's like yo guy comes
home after 19 years in jail like oh good
job maybe this is just my experience as
a Creator but like
people are just meaner over there I
don't know
um
compared to like YouTube I've had
hateful YouTube comments but it doesn't
hit as hard as like when you can see how
many people are liking the comments
like damn bro just let me post
you know [__] like that I mean I'm sure
I mean you just said you could I've
gotten it too but damn to that point I
didn't think dog was so awesome no the
main thing when I first started blowing
up for weed content people were mad that
I could post it and they couldn't right
understandably because like that's my
thing I made a video about Seth Rogen
saying like why can he do this but we
can't so people started doing that with
me and like a bunch of big Stoners on
Tick Tock were mad at me and then you
commented
holy [__] I say wait and I'm gone yeah
I thought oh I was like damn it's over
I'm happy that someone broke through
yeah okay no it's the opposite it's
always like yo the only time I've gotten
mad where I'm on Instagram like you got
a blue check mark [__]
all you do is post packs and I'm getting
delete that's when I got upset but no I
saw it I even commented like yo I'll say
take I'll say weed on here and I'm gone
I remember exactly what video was I
think he threw a joint caught it all it
was like a weird edit but it looks sick
how the [__] did he and I can't that's
the first time I ever heard of you yeah
because somebody but yo you gotta have
this dude on the pocket I'm like a
clinical he could post weed but then I
was like yo Tick Tock doesn't give a
[__] they just pick and choose because
sometimes I'll talk about weed and
they'll let it go yeah it's really weird
I I mean I wish I knew I mean I could
get like banned for saying this but I
went to a tick tock event a couple years
back and they had a list of questions we
couldn't ask them and most of them were
about like Banning and Views and things
like that and I think it's because they
don't even know right like tick tock's
not owned by people over here I don't
know what's going down with it so
oh yeah that's how it feels it feels
like everyone's in the dark when it
comes to tick tock rules there's a lot
of weirdness when it comes to that app
because uh my uh my cousin works for the
government and he's not allowed to have
it on his phone yeah yeah and he when he
because you have to leave your phone
with the guard at the front but you're
not even allowed to have it in your
phone app like at all anywhere because
it's just listening
they have no clue you know I don't know
yeah no one knows I don't know man so
you do you have no code there is no
recipe you're just like thanks for
letting it happen that's probably the
biggest comment or question I get like
how are you allowed to get away with
this how have you grown a weed content
on Tick Tock my answers I don't know I
got lucky do you find the people from
Tick Tock going to your like twitch and
Instagram and stuff I'd say my my my
twitch is mainly like Tick Tock viewers
is that kind of the real goal like if
they take my Tick Tock down I'm over
here on Twitch like heavy yeah I've for
the past like year or so I've kind of
wanted to get more into YouTube and
twitch so that's always been a good yeah
long form content man it's forever it's
more like gratifying too to like put out
a 30 minute video really cool edits and
stuff like a video 10 second Tick Tock
yeah then you feel like oh my God all
this [__] compiled into one long stream
thought exactly yeah it's cool I I feel
you dude because I was doing Instagram
um
before they had video and they just had
pictures obviously I would do like the
collage and do pictures as they made
like a stop motion yeah that's how I was
posting weed [__] as videos
I get what you're saying saying video
came like oh my God I like this so much
better and then I got a new to go I can
do 40 minute videos yeah yeah this is
where it's at it's a lot better okay so
the transition from YouTube I saw that
you're about to hit 75 on there yeah
that's a big number for posting five
times yeah
I saw it I had to click and refresh
oh you just started posting yeah I mean
I made some videos back in like my high
school days but those are long gone they
weren't I'm not like proud of those they
were just some goofy little videos but
now I'm taking it serious putting effort
into it my first few videos I had crazy
luck because they were monetized at
first they were like doing really well
100K views on the first like three and
then since then YouTube's been a little
mad at me like cut the age restrict yeah
go in the back end like all the bells
and all the [__] is at two percent one
percent no challenge suggestions it's so
crazy seeing the views going from like
there's an incline and then it just
flattens yeah it goes off the screen and
it's just up if you if you guys were to
start a channel from scratch and like
okay I'm not gonna smoke weed on this
channel at all I just want to give it
its best chance do you think like just
being explicit in what you're saying is
enough to have your [__] start on a
never-ending path I'll get DJ ghost
he talks about crazy [__] all across all
his channels and his [__] is steadily
like this and he smokes yeah it's true
but he has it pre-roll it's rolled up
it's not about the weed I think that's
why YouTube likes that it's not about
the weed yeah that's that's what I'm
trying to get into not about the weed
but you're still smoking yeah like right
now there's enjoying my hand exactly but
the show's not a weed podcast I mean
there might be some plant pictures I get
it
yesterday was a sober episode like the
guy doesn't smoke we even smoke the
whole time so there's like there's
I see what you're saying it's like you
know this could complement the the
content not be always just the content
YouTube just came out with some new
rules about like swearing though did you
see that what if you swear in the first
like eight seconds of the video now it's
demonetized instantly like no if hands
or butts but apparently it's like worse
than that people are getting demonetized
for swearing like three minutes in five
minutes in it's like another one of
those situations all right catch one
that's well
that's not good for me yeah at all and
I'll do so for YouTube
what do you have plant are you going to
be doing
in terms of content right now it's more
of a
stories do you follow Goblin yeah it's
kind of that field like yo video
gameplay monetized we crazy stories and
xcode is the same shit's like
you guys found a loophole you guys found
a [__] loophole to show your gaming
have fun and talk while getting paid
which is the ultimate goal dude so are
you gonna be doing anything else with
that channel like
do you see yourself I'm going to the
[__] Cannabis Cup uh do you see
yourself doing more
things that involve you because just for
my suggestion if you're trying to get
more of like yo my my videos are
not so much weeded he's got to be more
like you like people are gonna and you
already have the following people like
you
know what I'm saying so do you see
yourself doing
out and about [__] more than just like
the the gaming videos I mean eventually
right I'm still trying to get people
over to watch my streams my goal is to
get
streams like popping and then once that
happens in terms of twitch yeah once
that happens and I have like funding I
want to do some crazy events and [__]
like oh that's cool yeah but
the main goal right now is use the
gaming content and stuff from streams
you make that into an edit for YouTube
and then push people over there okay
let's find out what I'm working on
Twitch how long you've been doing that
I've been streaming on Twitch for three
years oh [__] yeah how often do you do
you stream every day besides Sunday [__]
yeah
damn that's a lot of work Jesus Christ
that's a schedule man it's all it is
yeah it definitely is I'm not really
scheduled like that's the main thing
about my streaming I just go live
whenever the [__] make my viewers
deal with it there it is there it is
dude because the past year what I've
noticed I've every Thursday the double
Joel Channel at three o'clock we post
new videos nearly impossible it's nearly
impossible and I [__] hate knowing
like oh this guy always says you know I
work on these days
I'm not gonna ever see a [__]
Premiere I go
yeah because I used to just go hey
uploading 40 minutes full get ready and
post on Instagram people go what the
[__] and be so hyped and now it's more
like oh it's every Thursday you don't
catch it Friday yeah
I mean like
I feel like it takes away from me the
fun the fun and like oh I gotta go check
was there anything new yeah cause that's
how I would I'm gonna go check and see
what you're saying it's a good point
yeah that makes people watch old videos
too yes because it's just checking yeah
see that's what I'm gonna start doing I
think I'm gonna take the every Thursday
off and just [__] go nuts do it post
whatever so once a week or twice I would
like to do twice a week man but
it's definitely hard is there games that
you just beat the shadow are you like
really good at a specific game or two or
do you just play everything and you're
I'm a variety streamer like I do
whatever my main things on stream are
just smoking and joking with the chat
and like making fun of people and [__]
that's a big thing we do over there you
watching the internet basically yeah
with the chat yeah that's pretty much it
um but games I just got into like the
Dark Souls series that [__] is so fun
it's never played it's very good I don't
I wish I could man but I feel like I get
so lost I'm addicted to games that I'll
never not stop playing
I get it you heard about Elden ring I've
heard of it okay Dad oh no my little
brother plays it yeah I just got it but
I haven't played it yet I recommend it
it's probably like the best game ever
what's like the if you had to describe
it in two sentences like the point of it
it's a open world game and you just kill
the bosses
it's a very difficult game but
yeah it's hard to explain you gotta
experience it's a whole experience like
that's how I can explain games it's
really what draws you it's like a movie
yeah my cousin Lukas plays the new Doom
have you ever played Doom yeah Doom
Eternal that [__] is so fun oh my God
it's like watching a [__] horror
movie
it was so dope
I remember Doom back in the day on the
PC yeah his face just ah in the corner
of your little life that's all you had
no now you're with demons Marty and you
can summon fools like in [__]
Grandma's Boy
Eternal Slayer or whatever Daryl death
Slayer you know much of a gamer at all
damn that's crazy these are recovering
yes oh okay I got an Xbox when I was 20.
and I missed two football games like I
wanted me to watch with him and I was
like I'm turning this thing in I can't
play it anymore I played UFC straight I
was like grab me I'll be right there
hours later I'm playing the game still
miss the whole game like dude this is
addicting
my thumbs hurt right now cause I just
got that it says
my kid's been whooping my [__] ass in
that UFC four and that's like I can't
stop I gotta all right run it back one
more God damn it I gotta edit this
[__] video one more yeah that's right
yeah yeah it is it's like you suck dick
yeah no his daughter's got to win on
fortnite and she's four these kids are
natural Gamers she's about to uh I know
fortnite is [__] difficult she won no
joke that game beats my first place
she's a lit she can't she's this tall as
she won not that confident if she didn't
hop on that UFC 4 she wouldn't be
[__] whipped my ass like Camus you
know what but what if she did that's
what I'm saying as a prophet
because you're imagining Savannah
I'm getting ready to wrestle her on
[__] YouTube yeah yeah she's cool
she's cool
um so for twitch real quick
my question is when you're done since
you play copywritten things and you're
playing on you show on YouTube you can't
save the video anymore
can't stay on I mean usually if you play
something copywritten on Twitch they'll
just mute that part of the VOD once it's
like uploaded right but they want VOD is
just a video file like yeah yeah I don't
know what it stands for it might Oh I
thought that's what it was video on
demand I was like the first time I ever
get it right it's not even it I'm not
sure but yeah they just muted I've never
I played copywritten music a lot I've
had like album reviews and [__] and
never had a strike oh mute it in the VOD
that's it doesn't like ruin the video I
mean if if like someone goes back to
watch an old stream through that's not
really what twitch is about huh yeah
it's about being there right yeah kind
of
see I didn't talk to people that do
twitch you know no bro what you're
thinking is not right yeah I do twitch
there's still a chance you'll get
copyrighted like hey if you're watching
this don't take my word for it you might
get in trouble but I haven't so good
[__] I feel like you're not like
malicious I feel like that's what these
these apps like he's just let him do his
thing yeah you know yeah but for the
most part I feel like you're just
getting left alone so what's your Twitch
handle uh Chris udala okay everything
yeah [__]
so lucky now this is the ultimate goal
yeah across all platforms
what's up guys taking a moment to talk
about one of our long time sponsors and
this is manscaped right now did you know
manscape just dropped some products for
your beards yes manscape is taking it
above and beyond and above the waistline
guys this is not for your dick
introducing your manscape beer hedger
Pro kit for all the people out there
that shape their beard try to get that
look now you can do it with manscape
five o'clock Shadows gigantic beards
whatever you got manscape can control it
first this is a cordless trimmer second
with the rotary wheel there are 20
different beard leg settings 20
different settings so you don't have to
have a drawer full of 16 attachments
it's one attacher that does 20 different
settings guys right now go to
manscape.com forward slash Yola that's
20 off of everything and anything you
can possibly buy and free shipping all
you got to do is use code Yola manscape
does not stop at just the trim they just
introduced beard shampoo and conditioner
so right now you can get the beard kit
it has three free gifts a beard comb
brush and scissors a whole kit to make
sure your beard doesn't look like [__]
so right now get 20 off everything and
free shipping by go to manscape.com
forward slash YOLO that's our code and
that's it remember the new beard hedger
one stroke one guard 20 different
lengths and always thank you so much for
supporting the sponsors that support us
back to the episode
I want to get into something
we had Josh obviously you know Josh yes
you before we start you work with raw
yeah what capacity Ambassador okay okay
cool
um when did you start doing that
um
I think like almost a year ago a little
under a year yeah oh okay so what did
you start working with raw
um they saw I made a rolling tutorial on
Tick Tock and then Josh saw it and it
was like yo we need to get you a better
tray I was using a shitty plastic tray
and he sent me some [__] and I was like
yo if y'all ever want to work with me
let me know and from there it became
this I got raw socks on right now I
don't think y'all can see but always
rapping you know thanks dude nice nice
so if it's been that long I'm not sure
if you watched the Josh episode that he
when he was on here but
I've known that full for like a [__]
decade right so
I always think I've asked him before
like dude
what are you gonna do you're gonna stay
here forever and be Willy Wonka
like what are you gonna do and then we
asked him are you looking for [__]
Charlie and he brought up
someone
he's I have someone in mind that would I
think could be to take over the factory
take over my [__] be my Charlie word
how old are you I'm 24.
probably it I mean how long ago did he
say that eight months ago
[__] maybe I might be Charlie that's
crazy might be Charlie because he said
he was very talkatively super [__]
nice he's a very positive dude and then
when we sat down I was like remember I
said it before you got here I'm like
dude
this is a guy [__] um Josh is talking
about those are some big [__] shoes
you better be ready man that's right
crazy but when he said it
you moved to Arizona
yeah I mean do you ever not want to
say when he asked was your hesitant he
didn't ask me to move here first off
like that was kind of my own play I've
always wanted to get out of Minnesota
like I just wanted to live somewhere
legal first off somewhere warmer didn't
mean to go to hell on accident that's
Arizona but bro you went 180 you went
full [__] let me see if I can survive
the heat yeah I went in the middle of
August too
probably all those sweaters
damn that sucks
um so no no I wanted to ask that because
Josh said something I thought about that
I wonder what he's talking about
that was like nine months ago and then
right one year before you got here I was
thinking
I think it's the dude so has it been
like worth it are you glad you made that
move
like to move out to Arizona yeah yeah
it's been worth it for sure I've learned
a lot just being like out on this side
of the country because this is more
where weed is talked about and I've gone
to some cannabis events and [__] that
was real cool in Arizona yeah I can't
wait to get out of there though like I
think one year is enough people are mean
down there are they yeah maybe I'm soft
but like compared to Minnesota you know
Minnesota nice that's like the thing
people say about it but I don't know
that oh really oh yeah well I know
nothing
yeah no one I forget like no one cares
but
you guys got Fargo now right Fargo you
mean the movie the movie yeah it's
Minnesota is it oh it is oh it is she's
telling Bobby Hill I don't watch TV
honest no Fargo's a movie from like
[__] 95. on this yes
it's new to me yeah damn you don't watch
movies no from 95. oh about that to be
honest oh okay you say you don't watch
any shows or nothing I'm not much of a
TV guy I grew up on the Internet so I'm
a YouTube twitch type of guy that's me I
watch anime got a bunch of anime on my
shirt like what kind of the only anime I
know is uh
see already forgot
come on come on what the [__] his name
you can help me all right we'll see how
much
you ready
it's badass it's [__] from like 1998
maybe 2000
most anime come on it's one [__] dude
he has one sick ass name he kills the
[__] out of fools it's like a modern day
I feel so stupid right now
all my homies watching anime but me so
I'm really like from Merced word I feel
so stupid it's a badass one I guarantee
and already got it yeah they're mad at
us my homie used to watch it all the
time it's a movie
it's like an anime like movie it's two
[__] hour it's like two hours plus
it's very very graphic and it's badass
this guy's got one
one exactly one [__] name
I feel so brain dead I don't know I've
never known any of them yeah anyway I
knew of one yeah that's good I guarantee
if you bring it up like yeah that
movie's the [__] I've never gone to damn
it watch Dragon Ball Z a few times
yeah I watched that as a kid that was it
dude once I got into like college I
started watching anime heart I watched
hunter hunter that one highly recommend
and then there's this one about dudes
playing volleyball I know how it sounds
but it's like it's one of the best
things ever they make they make the
games into like a whole fight damn near
I love it so the thing about anime is
like yo I'm gonna punch you but we're
gonna go to space while we do it come
back yeah it's all about the Pediatrics
you know yeah a lot of having the
Pokemon go head full is killing
themselves I literally play that to this
day do you really still going bro out
here was nuts bro it was nuts fools were
getting robbed fools were getting robbed
every day because they were going to
find rare Pokemon and game Banger fools
were waiting at the site to rob people
yeah that [__] was the clever that was a
clever moment
no but it isn't like yo they got a phone
definitely got car keys or or a wallet
not paying portable charger something
but you know they got something it was
[__] Omar match man oof he lived
outside catching Pokemon
cool phase in life where I saw like a
lot of the world like you guys are all
collectively having fun in some ways
it's pretty cool 2016 like that talks
about summer 16 because it was such a
good summer I think the only reason was
because of Pokemon go that's Pokemon go
and the music of that year the time has
gone by that was 2016. yeah
we're saying that was like seven years
ago yup or old as [__] bro are you
[__] kidding me that was that long
ago I would have put that out about two
years ago I was gonna say about maybe
three to four no well I feel stupid the
killer clowns thing was kind of similar
yeah you just had that out there talking
about that yeah there were some in my
neighborhood that [__] was so stupid
didn't even ever get hurt oh definitely
right I would have shot something
stories I would imagine you'd get shot
in the head real quick that's an
ultimate fear especially in Arizona well
no you're on Minnesota yeah no one was
doing [__] about it but like I'm sure in
Texas down south something something bad
happened probably question yeah what's
the
what's the process of getting weed in
Minnesota
you find a plug you get weed from the
plug that's that's I mean like in the
terms of what's the process like is
there variety do you have [__] to choose
from it depends if you're in the cities
you can find like you you could find a
plug with a crazy ass menu if you're in
the country you buy the blue dream that
the plug promises he has you know
flat slightly drowned as hell
yeah I've had like some Cocoa Pebbles
ass no in the United States that's
insane
but like that was that was in my
youngster days once I got out to college
once I was going to college I went to
the U of M I was running track and field
out there oh no [__] yeah oh nice so
you're fat what is that noise so that's
my foot okay you're fast as [__] or you
do you do high jump I was a long jump
long jump I knew it was something I ran
to but long jump and triple jump on my
things so you blow your knees out
basically because triple jump shouldn't
work yeah that [__] shouldn't exist oh
is that what you said yeah and because I
was smoking weed a lot like those were
the two main reasons I was getting
tested for college yeah I was D1 you
they were talking oh oh oh that's all
you had to say bro I was an athlete for
real you read D1 triple jumper yeah
that's over the little hurdles no it's
this one two and then you do the long
jump you're gonna break your legs
basically yeah that [__] don't make
sense to me like your your legs
shouldn't be able to
[__] that [__] it's there's a video of
me that went viral just of me busting my
ass one time like I won our sections
meet with a jump where I face planted
and I thought that was pretty safe wait
why wouldn't you just always do that you
get more more nah it seems like you
would go further but your face always
hits the ground way too early if you go
like that we've tried it many times have
you ever folded your ass in half like
trying to jump and you know get you know
how people get their legs out they do
that hit your ass and turn things so you
don't flop back yeah have you ever just
crunched your [__] dead stopped no
that's what I imagine I got into like
the the good Landings in college like in
high school when I was jumping I wasn't
I was just landing on my feet because I
could never get the landing down but
once I got into it it's not that hard
you just push your legs out to the side
you kind of roll and you roll with it
yeah I watched the Olympics heavy bro
that that jump doesn't make sense but
the triple jump I always say like how do
humans do it I was just explaining to my
son like track is like kind of the
coolest sport because there's like all
these little Sports within it and it's
like kind of you're not gonna get hurt
for any other sports it's going to make
you better at those other sports like if
you really think about doing track if
y'all ever watched gymnastics at all no
it's just I don't understand how people
are so strong I was coaching gymnastics
for a while that was my first job
actually can you do a backflip I could
do one
oh maybe Stevo yeah he could definitely
do a backflip first yeah yeah they could
no it's always a goal I always talk
about live like one day I'm be able to
do a [__] backflip it's not as hard
as you think literally most of it is
fear like there is a chance to break
your [__] but like it's it's mainly
about I think it's like can I get high
enough to throw my head back and it
doesn't hit the ground I don't know
when I was a kid I used to get almost
like
over and land on my chest like as a kid
yeah
if I had some big buff dude going hey
with his hand on my back flipping me
yeah that was me I wasn't a little buff
though 15 at the time coaching so
coaching your high school yeah I coached
I mean there was a need for like
spotters and coaches I was living out in
the country at the time in Minnesota so
they just threw me in young as hell had
me carrying people heavier than me
trying my best to throw them it was a
crazy job it was probably like some of
the most fun I've had besides when I was
getting like farted on or watching
people break their [__] like break their
arms in gymnastics yeah I was alone
coaching one day this was I was probably
like 17 I don't even know if I was
supposed to be alone I hope I'm not
snitching on myself but um there was no
like adult supervising I was just
coaching one of our classes and a girl
did a round off which is like a
cartwheel with a little spring and she
was gonna go into a back handspring the
thing yeah she knew how to do it on her
own she was gonna go into it and she got
scared put her arm out behind her you
could see where that goes right it just
that was messed up a year got hurt doing
track track I mean yeah I have a couple
hernias oh wait he said that you're back
sorry her needed this that's what I have
in a deteriorating disc it sucks yeah
it's not fun so that's how you did it
while jumping yeah blew your disc out I
mean that's that's what led me to
quitting like I could have gotten
surgery but I didn't I'm scared don't do
it I need to just you just stretch they
told me to get surgery on mine I'm like
nah bro yeah you ever get those like
injections no hell no I don't go that
far it helps Loki it does the cortisone
yeah but it helps it's scary and those
needles are big as hell remember the guy
that put one in my head yeah full hit me
in the head without telling me with a
quarter Zone needle because I had to
deviated septum and it was like causing
hella pressure would you want a shot I
go no I think I'm gonna turn and he goes
wait and he just dicks me dude no that's
making me feel weird into my temple and
I felt like he's all don't move and he
stopped and he went like this and put a
tape over it
I'm gonna [__] hit him no it helped
but don't stick me with a [__] needle
that's been without telling me that's
terrifying I'm so terrified and I'm like
yo how's it still going my skull it's my
story and I'm like how are you still
just in your brain I don't know maybe I
would maybe like I thought it was going
in for a hell of further but that needle
you know the pictures this is huge and
it's wide
the cortisone shots damn your backs are
hurting yeah yeah your back's [__] it
sucks that sucks I heard my back when I
was 21.
so I feel you were you really bummed out
when you had to stop doing track I heard
it in high school right I heard it as a
junior in high school and kind of like
just bullshitted my way I tried my best
to hide it until my sophomore year of
college you were still jumping with it
yeah and then it got to a point where I
like couldn't walk really like that pain
down the ragness and like it just
shooting down yeah shooting down to your
calf to your foot too so that's yeah the
pinch that's when I had to stop but like
if I if I Sprint right now it'll hurt
for a day and then it'll feel pretty
much better the main time it hurts is
when I'm rolling over in bed yeah do you
sleep on your side yeah stop but that's
the number one thing but it feels good I
know if we get to put a pillow there and
a pillow next to you so you don't turn
that's the stage I'm in for the past
eight months because my chiropractor's
like your diss stop sleeping on your
[__] side that's the number one thing
you that would hurt your disc damn damn
dude last night I slept with my side I
was like I don't care I don't [__]
care and I woke up just did my whole
disc was [__]
damn that sucks man I'm sorry to hear
that I mean I'm it kind of worked out
for the better like I was planning on
quitting the track because yeah sure I
also was like planning on dropping out
of school at the time that was a whole
other thing was that for you yeah it
wasn't for me and like I was I wanted to
be a full-time streamer I was already at
a point where I was doing kind of well
with it because I had two million
followers on Tick Tock at the time while
going to school yeah oh [__] cool
how long ago was this
um sophomore year college so I'm old bro
I don't remember
three years ago that long ago I don't
know pandemic is like oh no I feel you
on that one yeah I always forget those
two years it's crazy how'd your parents
feel about that I mean my mom is pretty
supportive my dad is
very supportive I mean he's from Nigeria
so I like telling an African parent I'm
dropping out of school I'm gonna smoke
weed
like it doesn't sound too good but then
I told him like how much I'm making and
where this could go and my back it
doesn't work I mean yeah but like that I
didn't have to drop out of school
because of my back oh you know you're
right you're right smoking weed every
day and like my main focus was just
growing my internet Persona which I mean
it's not the best move but I'm lucky it
worked out
well any saw that you want what you
wanted to do I well [__] Eric do you
have you ever met Eric Khan before I
haven't met him but I've watched him
forever okay he literally was what a
couple months a half a semester away
from being done and he stopped school
he's like nah bro I'm gonna yeah go this
route that's the first thing he talked
we talked about when he came on the show
he had quit just a couple months before
and he was in a four-year college and he
would just last year decided in uh
streaming doing this is where I need to
be
so if you're dedicated and you are
willing to
take lucky it worked out see most people
are not willing to take the look it
worked out yeah they have to have a for
sure thing I mean I I kind of felt like
I had a for sure-ish thing as for sure
as the internet goes because popping the
top on that yeah yeah seen that
um but I had two million followers on
Tick Tock at the time if I streamed on
Twitch I knew I could pull over enough
people so I was
I at least felt like I could rely on
that
if I didn't have the the following or
the fan base at the time there's no way
I would have dropped out for it right
yeah like if I just thought I want to be
a content creator that didn't have the
following I don't think I would have
gone for it or because the following two
because the following have been taken
tomorrow but you're gonna build it back
up because you know what you want to do
yeah okay it's like you said [__] if
they take my Tick Tock it's time to go
yeah exactly
see that's the only way that you'll last
that's the only way that you're going to
be here when you're 33 34 you know what
I mean that's the only way because most
people go oh
can't monetize this
uh oh I not willing to [__] quit
school or not willing to go I just did
eight hour shift still stream for what
the [__] nobody cares if you just got
off work hurry up
that's the only way dude I've seen
hundreds of these fools just
do dope [__] and just all right delete
it oh I don't want to no no I'm done
yeah so good battling the platform since
the start so it's whatever it is about
Instagram what do you do you post like
weed [__] there I've never cared about
Instagram like I was growing for a time
I went up like a hundred thousand
followers on Instagram and I was really
excited and then I just realized like I
don't take pictures I don't want to post
my videos on here it doesn't feel the
same clip you post the clip and go hey
new episodes up yeah it's your uh
mailing list okay yeah use it as
Advertiser bro that's kind of how I use
tick tock now though so I guess perfect
use both of them now use them all power
them all up dude because the only
because a lot of people don't have Tick
Tock or SnapChat or something else but
they have Instagram or a lot of people
don't [__] have anything but Snapchat
you know what I'm saying you know what
I'm saying so there's always people on
Twitter that do not [__] with Instagram
I know you know that there's fools that
like oh I'm on Twitter because why
whatever on Instagram
so I know you [__] Twitter too yeah
Twitter's fun yeah see Twitter smokes
you're doing whatever the [__] you want
talk [__] you can say whatever you want
go hey don't watch them people hate on
Twitter just because it's like the most
toxic platform I don't see that oh you
don't I don't see any of the stuff are
you on you're not you know like 15
people you just see happy [__] pretty
much for the most part your life is sick
right or I just disrespected somehow
despite are you watching this [__]
world star fights and [__] I haven't
been doing in a long time because
YouTube decided to take it the [__] off
the internet you two took all the world
star comps off and there's only like
eight left damn
that's not easy to do you want to watch
like Street beefs these dudes on shout
out to Street piece I know I know you're
watching I know you're watching they ask
us the dope is support to sponsor
they're trying to figure it out but hell
yeah fair play be [__] fools up all
right shots in that [__] with
the suspenders you beat the [__] out of
people sometimes I feel so bad they're
like coming in uh six two giant [__] uh
49 year old white man that's never
fought in his life he has basketball
shorts little dude has a [__] Walmart
shirt and he's punching over hand like
don't do that dude this man's got
entertainment though it is but sometimes
it's like who the [__] set this up
they're not even the same weight limit
those dudes are they're with it though
usually like they want to squash that
beef they they're Brave you know braver
than me I wouldn't get in the ring with
someone that much bigger than me dude
sometimes it's it's not we need to do
commentary as well sometimes it's not
fair sometimes it's just but sometimes
I'm like I was watching yesterday I go
one of these kids gonna get picked up
into a [__] fighting lean because
some of these fools are [__] good at
fighting yeah some of them some of them
are like wow you know what the [__]
you're doing ending a fight in one round
like
yeah as the drunk dude next door but
still yeah you know what you're doing
we're talking about just like regular
Street beefs is a [__] cage someone
made in their backyard Marty and the
floor is dirt and people fight on it
gotcha to like squash their like real
life yeah sometimes it'd be like real
life problems and they'll walk up like
[__] that mother a [__] and we'll just
start fighting with the clothes no they
have like an Anthem like Put the gun
down put the fists up that's their whole
like thing it's kind of sick I think
it's cool I I there was one of them one
of the versions of it was really bad and
me and my fiance used to sing it all the
time
no I'm trying to think of it I knew the
words to it it was super good it's like
put your fists up or some [__] yeah but
the gun sticks wait literally what he
just [__] said I'm trying to catch
the Rhythm in my head because I know the
song Me and Rosie were saying all the
time
[__] Street beefs anyway yeah it's
like USC but very unregulated then the
way classes are like
how old are you guys you're close enough
in age just fight yeah anyway like the
oldest to youngest as kids that's pretty
much Street beef's like yo
just [__] fight him because there's
some there are some
some like actual big [__] fools that
walk in the ring I've seen this one guy
that gets on there all the time with
like my haircut it's all
his hair is always shagging [__] but
he's a big [__] wife I see his ass
get knocked sorry I'm talking about
streaming too much my bad let me get off
Street piece guys my bad anyway yes I
have seen Street beef yeah are you into
like UFC and MMA or anything not that
much I used to be I want to get back
into it I haven't really been watching
sports I've been streaming every day
streamers don't watch sports you know
yeah I don't I don't know well I have
one stream one streamer the streamer is
just like dorky gamer type Vibe and I
have I've fully accepted that I went
from athlete to dorky gamer I'm an
athlete
athlete to mathlete yeah I'm a beer fest
I guess that's what it's called nerds
mathlete
so wait
you're an athlete your whole life you
grew up Minnesota are you a [__]
Vikings fan I feel like you have to be I
mean I support them when they're doing
good oh no okay so you're like uh [__]
the Vikings yeah because can you name
one Viking besides Dante Culp every
Randy Moss I can't bro I should be able
to as a Minnesotan but like I'm not
going to just to make them mad in the
comments
[__] okay hold on are you an only child
no I got two sisters younger older one
older one younger I'm a middle child
yeah all right all right what do they do
for like work and [__] uh
one's in college the other one she
[Music]
[__] what is she doing damn all right we
can't we can't air this no more I think
I think she was working at a makeup
store recently I don't know what her
vibe is right now oh okay okay they live
back in Minnesota too yeah damn what's
the life in Minnesota give me the day
like the day because he grew up in
Buffalo where it's snow and it's brick
outside is where all you [__]
say so I've heard that from somebody
from Buffalo
so what do you do like what did you do
in Minnesota when there's no weed
okay there's normally weed though that's
the thing you can no matter where you're
at you can find weed the quality is what
differences it's such a different vibe
for me yeah
you do whatever I mean in the cities
there's a lot to do it
Minneapolis is Little Chicago right like
that's that's the Box yeah Minneapolis
is just a smaller version of that I'd
say I always I always want to ask like
what did you do because I know what I
did like oh we all tried to like look at
The Sandlot put your money together and
get a [__] baseball and over there
it's like yo how many how much we can we
all get if we all put our way together
and all our money together and we'll get
one Little Caesar's Pizza yeah because
it's five dollars we all got a dollar on
it no we were skateboarding is big in
Minnesota oh is it yeah I mean like when
it when when it's not well snow brings
obviously the second yeah there's a lot
of snowboarders out there I've never
snowboarded as a Minnesotan I want to
it's so bad but yeah you never just I
mean obviously snows are here right you
never went outside and just [__]
hopped up I mean I never had a snowboard
someday I want to go to like some crazy
ass Mountain big bang big bear up here
and they have Mammoth I've never been to
Mammoth but California's a spot dude
okay yeah I've never I've been snow when
I was like six I was a little fat kid
and wear sweats outside my jeans and
they both got wet and they got all heavy
and I got pissed and I just gave up
that's my only snowboarding career
so real quick we're gonna do something
um a little segment we're gonna ask you
two things we're gonna ask you I guess a
question and you just tell us how do you
feel about that this segment's called
where you at all right so where are you
at with what we're talking about Marty
made up the segment and I feel like it's
a really good one it goes into so many
different topics so Marty if you want to
start that all right where are you at
with well see we can always do this but
we gotta this isn't really aware yet but
falls under it
16 year old version of yourself walks in
here oh that one I don't know let's do
that all right that's technically the
start to where you're at okay and he's
pissed
who wins in a fight
you know you walks in 16. and wants to
beat the [__] out of you are you gonna
beat the [__] out of him beat my little
ass all right then all right all right
oh you're running a little 16 year olds
just a scrappy little kid I wasn't I was
bigger in college but like 16 I was a
little dude
most people are like not able to shot me
like most guests like no that would have
stabbed me or like no that 16 year old
me was crazy I was pretty chill not good
good because that's me like I'm 16 year
old me would have beat the [__] at me
but my same reaction I was just chilling
we need to make a highlight reel
everybody's immediate reaction yeah
like oh hell no damn is this a good is
it good like test of like are you
physically fit if 16 year old you could
mop you get in shape yeah six year old
me was different than a little buff [__]
that's not fair if 16 year old me starts
running he's gone
I'll never even make it to this
yeah exactly I'll make sure I die damn
Jesus yo that's some Inception yeah I
like that was good sorry continue all
right where are you at
where you at with germs overall in
general
the five second rule if you drop
something on the floor is it disgusting
or you touching door handles in public
places you drop a [__] on snow and still
eating it I would I mean as a kid I was
eating snow like I don't know I would
definitely take a bite doing that I mean
I'd probably still take a bite but yeah
it's it's whatever if I draw okay five
second rule depends if it's sticky right
like if I drop a Jolly Rancher ew you
know that's over
if I drop a whole burger right and it
stays completely in Burger shape and
just bounces
you know I'ma probably pick that [__] up
I might even give it 15. like I'll give
it oh [__]
I said 15 second rule okay okay so the
other day hold on after we I won't say
who one of our friends was drunk
and I was walking back to the car so our
friend could drive him home he's just
[__] up we'll dropped one of our
sharks mid e one of our gummy sharks
no onto the ground of my parking lot
It could only be one person
grabbed it oh stopped them I'm like no
no I did I gave the if you have a bag in
your hand but I don't waste it like bro
please waste it it was a two second rule
no any public place you cannot I guess I
always imagine someone took a [__] there
last night yeah of course I was gross
when I was a kid right away if I saw
like a piece of candy on the ground in
my house like I'm eating that that's
that's going in my mouth I got a [__]
up story so I found what I thought was a
Tic Tac right it was just chilling in my
room and I was like oh [__] I'm gonna
I'm gonna eat this I was like 11 10
something like that I go to take a bite
and I couldn't get through it it was
like like it just stuck in my mouth and
I eventually cracked it but I was like
oh what the [__] spit it out and then I
went back for it I was like let me just
swallow it I come to find out that was
probably a tooth I don't have
confirmation but my little sister lost
her tooth that day
you ate some bones so yeah I potentially
put it ate Bones on accident is that
like illegal to admit am I like getting
locked up for this one no no no
so for sure teeth can break teeth I mean
it's a baby I'm not sure if I one of
them cracked it could have been my tooth
it was I was using my molar I never
really like could you imagine you
cracked your own tooth it was just a
rock
um
it was just a white thing and I was just
like I'm eating it yo your appetite's
crazy
nowadays I'm good right now there's a
weight to buy [__] from the store yeah
McDonald's I don't live too far Not Just
Eat random I'm not eating teeth anymore
the only uh story I've ever heard this
guy named John used to do uh moving with
in Portland
he told me I handed him some candy and
he always did this I mean always the
first time he went like that
I I was like bro I'm not gonna dose you
like I was only 15 at the time of year
[__] 40 bro don't worry I'm not gonna
get you plus I would take the drugs
myself I'm not gonna get you um
and then I noticed that he did it again
and I was like dude what the [__] he was
I had to check everything out before I
eat it and then he told me when he was
12 he was with his homies and he's just
so crack and him and his homies were
like slaying crack and he was like I was
eating lemon heads in my pocket I pulled
some out I'm eating them I'm eating them
I pull some out and I'm chewing I'm
chewing and I wonder like
and a little bag he came on his teeth
like stuck on his tooth and he swallowed
a whole crack rock a hole like dead a
dub of it and he was like bro I was
[__] on one I was gone so I can't not
eat something without staring at making
sure and then eating it that's crazy so
five second rule was different from him
but yes you ate a tooth and he ate a
crack rock so that's okay I actually
swallowed like what a gram of coke once
and that was
no this one but it was it was a waste of
money how long did you accidentally
swallowed it my homie told me to gum the
bag I was like 16. oh and I just flipped
it inside out without looking I went
and he goes wrong back and I turned to
him like whoa your night's over because
that was all the rest of the drugs we
had
we were on fire for like hours or not no
it just got numb real numb like right
here I was on one let's not talk about
drugs anymore
let's go to the other segment and it
doesn't have nothing to do with drugs
where are you at with superstitious
thoughts
OCD style number counting numerology
going on in your head you one of those
people you're knocking out wood when you
think of some terrible Final Destination
thoughts nah no not really okay are you
good for you but nowadays I'm life is
weird and I've just accepted it I let I
let things be superstitions are too much
for me I don't know
all right no good for you [__] you don't
have to worry man yeah like what are
what are some of your superstitions
I don't think they're superstitions but
I think they're more manifestation [__]
now okay because again right here if I
if I some [__] hits me in the head I'm
like no
I can't think about that [__] that [__]
might happen because it's happened
before and I'm like oh no my full dies
and [__] like not taking the risk I'll
do this and look like a dummy before I
let some [__] happen because I'm on like
some
like did was that me like did I think of
that and it happened because it's
happened so it's like it's not
Superstition it's more of
my bad guys sorry
yes that's kind of how I am too oh I
want to hear this one
no
solo
are you jumping out of a plane or deep
sea cave diving if you have to do one
jumping out of a plane that shake of the
head
what the [__] the ocean is so scary
can you imagine getting on the beach and
30 minutes later at the bottom of the of
the ocean in someone's in something's
body Yeah by getting eaten I'd be
[__] you're still alive
chilling in a whale's stomach bro how
mad I'd be
what if he ate a shark and I had to
fight that [__] in his stomach
the shark looks real though inside the
whale's stomach God damn [__] double
stomach that'd be nice I would rather
die I'd starve to death inside of a
whale's stomach under the ocean than try
to swim back out and wonder if I'm in
the middle of the water
God this is the worst [__] fear of
all time oh my God float for a few hours
before you drowned
look
have you ever seen those like caving
videos of the dudes that go inside I'd
rather do that than go underwater
I would never cave like that is this
claustrophobic doesn't get me really a
little bit so you wouldn't feel a little
weird knowing you're literally under the
Earth just like oh man I wouldn't it's
scary because like yo I could get stuck
and die but it's not scary for me to be
in small spaces okay word at all right
honestly like when people are in crowds
like not even nothing like I'm getting
squished like nothing whatsoever I just
do this [__] I got stuck in an elevator
one time and thought I was gonna die for
like two minutes only but like the
elevator getting stuck is scary
depending on what kind of building
you're in like when you walked in and
like there was like Tweakers outside
like bro no one's coming for us there's
no front desk guy we're dead you know
what I mean but I got a hotel I'm sure
they're gonna get us the [__] out they
need to use it but I feel you my mom's
mad scared I'm mad scared of elevators
too every time we get on I can see her
every time my grandpa the scariest man
that we talked about in Ted Talk That
murderer [__]
he is so scared when he came to my
apartment
because he had to walk down the hallway
and he got my apartment he's super
claustrophobic a [__] apartment I saw
him and he was standing there like
looking down I'm like why does my scary
Grandpa look scared are you being scared
of heights no he's just afraid of the
apartment being so small he's a truck
driver
a diesel all day and sits in a coffin
all day sorry it was just really funny
to bring up yeah claustrophobic [__] not
even not even a little bit I would
rather sleep in like a little sleeping
bag and have no room just knowing like
you know no monsters are out there as a
kid and when I can make a cocoon of
myself like ah [__] yeah that's how I
barely oh that's the opposite thank God
not me I don't I can't have a shirt be
too [__] tight I don't like oh I
can't sleep next to the wall I'd rather
sleep next I'd rather sleep on the floor
right next to that corner because nobody
can get up behind me and [__] nobody can
[__] with me
I got restaurants I have to sit to the
[__] little wall I can't let like
let's get on another topic Jesus Christ
come on [__] like thinking of Mafia
hits and [__] like oh [__] back to the
wall go ahead my bed
so where you at with uh I call it
vehicles for your cannabis if you had to
pick one for the rest of your life
Blunt's papers bongs dabs pens which one
are you running with for Life
exclusively I'm a joint guy I've been
that way and like I'm not just saying
that because I'm a raw brand ambassador
I got off blunts when I got to college
for track and field I was like let me
take care of my lungs a little bit you
know I still want to smoke every day but
maybe no more tobacco so I'm just I like
joints I like how natural it feels I
like tasting my weed [__] like that
when did you start smelling weird I was
like 14 15. oh nice yeah who did it
who's the one that did it to you my
friend Nick yeah yeah one of my homeboys
I don't know if I'm not supposed to like
say his name but like you find out later
and bleep it if you have to yeah okay it
was Goblin Nick oh there you go yeah
um he just we were we were out in some
like wooded area back in my hometown and
he was like you want to smoke a bowl I
was like [__] it that's really all it
took that's it you were curious yeah I
never I never really had experience with
weed I was just like I want to smoke
someday I might as well get it out of
the way now and then we went to Walmart
I accidentally stole a box of protein
bars I didn't realize I grabbed it and I
was just like yeah this [__] looks good
as hell no I just like kept holding it
and just walking walked out yeah I
didn't realize it was there I just kept
moving you know dude you're an athlete
it's full got high I was like I need to
go steal protein bars no I never eat
those either
[Laughter]
if I just started doing drugs
so damn your homie Nick got you smoking
and then how long was it after until
you're like
I get my own sacks now
three days oh damn you got hooked I mean
I wasn't it's the most fun immediately I
just realized like wait everyone does
this [__] I never realized that until I
started smoking and asking other people
that you smoke and they're like yeah is
your mom and dad smoke yeah no or the
way you said that are they very like
religious I mean my parents are pretty
religious but they're not they're just
not really for smoking my dad's always
been trying to like
telling me to make my content less
smoking related oh really yeah but he he
doesn't really get this side of the
internet he doesn't see how like the
weed tube scene has been around forever
you know [__] like that
so I never heard that one yeah I've
never heard a parent like I would like
you to dial it back oh yeah that's
that's really all he says my mom is kind
of the same way she'll text me every now
and then and be like hope you're not
using all this she calls smoking using
which is crazy and where's your mom from
she's from Minnesota I knew that's from
Nigeria yeah how the hell they meet uh
my dad came out to Tennessee and then
I don't know they ended up linking at
the Mall of America some oh what yeah
that's that's all I know take the Mall
of America that you're here that's
amazing yeah Colin smoking weed using is
hilarious
bro yeah I'm just over here using oh I'm
gonna start saying the used trees
damn using oh damn that makes it feel
even worse yeah that's right sorry Mom
let me take this thing off my arm real
quick so your parents are like
uh we would like you to smoke less yeah
but they they understand that like this
is what I do yeah and like my my fan
base like it I like it it works you know
and that's all it really matters bro
yeah you know like it's not like you are
staying in their room yeah exactly
you're doing your own thing also how do
you What did your sisters think about it
they smoke I don't know oh my little
sister snitched on me for Vaping one
time like I don't Vape anymore she's
yeah so of course she sits on your shoes
okay it was crazy because she asked can
I hit you a vape I had it in the car I
was driving her to my dad's one day and
she said you have a vape and I was like
yeah and then I said you want to hit it
or something and she was like for sure
it starts dying of course and then
right after like I drop her off at my
dad's I head back home I get a call from
her or call from my mom like why the
hell did you let it Desi hit your Vape
so pissed oh well okay okay that's maybe
she got sick and she just said oh I hear
The Vape I think she just snitched okay
if you watch this I remember
oh hater how you gonna hit this [__] and
be involved did you say hey she actually
brought it and she made me hit it that's
how it is
hell yeah what's she gonna say no it
wasn't
well let's shoot him into the smoking
the worst man you're [__] toes are
the worst thing I ever did
um I won't say anything but I have a
step brother I don't really [__] with
and uh we were cool when we were in high
school and he's older than me and we
were going to high school together we I
got kicked out and moved to Oregon
he smoked cigarettes a lot and he would
sneak off and find cigarette butts at
the stores bro and smoke them that's
despicable it was horrible I never
smoked weed with him because like bro
you're gonna get [__] herpes and give
it to me bro and they put it on their
spoons and give to our little sisters
what are you doing
give a drink to our little sister now
you [__] their face up yeah so that was
like always pissed off
anyway he was moving away he was gonna
move with his dad right he's my step
brother he's gonna go back to his dad's
and he always smoked so what I did is I
smoked a little bit of weed I was like
you know what
[__] it I'm not going outside it's cold
I smoked I used to smoke cigarettes I
was younger and I had some weed and I
boxed the bathroom at like four or five
in the morning because nobody comes
upstairs to that bath I'm like [__] it
who gives this [__] and I blow the smoke
out the window does it work don't it
still [__] stinks I promise you guys
I always thought I was sleep turning the
water on no
and then it was like 5 30 in the morning
I come out and right when I'm coming out
I'm walking down the hallway and I see
my stepmom
I don't know why she's in the [__]
hallway
but I see you're not looking and just do
this go
ES
it smells in there she goes looks and
she smokes she goes
she goes in my stepbrother's room she
starts smacking the [__] out of him he
was about to move two hours later he
came up I swear I swear I walked
that's the worst thing I ever did to
somebody damn that's funny as hell but
he's a piece of [__] he's always smoking
in the bathroom I was like you know what
I'll do it this time and blame it on his
ass because he's [__] moving anyway
he
keep hours later so it's not like
oh she got the repercussions yeah you
were within your rights to do that [__]
yeah but I think she was out there it
was [__] up dude I felt bad as a room
like
I could hear her yelling like oh [__] in
Spanish oh no
[__] it and when I went back out there
she was spraying I went
and your sister you know maybe maybe it
was a slip-up yeah maybe she like maybe
she smelled Dragon she's like yo I Vaped
or maybe she smelled it what did you
smell like he he let me hear his name
Christopher's name okay yeah it might
have been one of those [__] hands up
moments bro yeah cause that's what mine
was
okay okay so the parents don't uh would
like you just use less you don't know if
your sisters smoke yet one of them
snitched on you all right caught up to
your family I feel like we know him
better now do you have cousins that
smoke weed or anything you have anybody
in your family you connect with and on
that level not really no damn that sucks
yeah and the ones that I do know I'm not
gonna say anything because their parents
are not cool with it so oh so you grew
up in that kind of family I mean that's
more just like
my Nigerian side of my family they're
not they're not really cool with weed so
[__] all right yeah that's really good
well it's a business at this point so
maybe in the future they're like yeah
yeah you see them look at him making
money it took eight years to be able to
tell my grandma the same [__] damn it
took no night it pissed me off like you
get all rich through weed and now
they're all cool with it like no you
know what [__] it let it be like you
know as long as you're here that's fine
with me yeah I find you because they're
straight no drinking no smoking nothing
bro you don't work to 18 hours a day
you're a [__] my grandma and grandpa
because they're hard working as
immigrant fools so yeah I've told them
what I did
and I showed him a [__] billboard and
that was the craziest moment of my life
and my grandma was like oh I love it
damn I told this it's fake smoke you
know on there but you know it was it was
fake Smoke on the front but not the bag
but I was like whoa I can't believe it
so I hope one day bro yeah I hope one
day that you could do that like yeah
look they're rocking your shirt and [__]
because it takes a while it took a long
time
for my how long you've been doing this
fully as we like four years four years
now yeah it took us you're six to I was
like actually like yeah that's what I do
but not my grandma grab so it just takes
time man yeah and you have immigrant
parent just like my immigrant grandma
grandpa it's different when you're like
you're gonna do drugs and show everybody
that you [__] drug addict that's
pretty much how they think too yeah so I
feel you man it'll take time but you'll
get there so I just lagged on that joint
forever I'm so sorry all right next one
that took [__] ever I'm sorry do you
let the fans know that you finally found
your pack
oh yeah that oh yeah I'll talk to you
about it yeah I finally found some weed
guys season one since we last said this
it's been two years since I found weed
to buy like pounds to buy yeah because I
just want to smoke it
everything burning black and go oh
tastes like [__] too I bought so many
half pounds I'm like oh
heartache bro that's money it's not
supposed to be a sad experience go re-up
and chill I know I'm a picky
[__] are you I mean oh wait wait
you're from Minnesota yeah so I had the
Arizona wheat it's a little better it's
better
it depends if you're willing to spend
like 40 to 60 dollars an eighth right
yeah well what about the ounce an ounce
300 bucks for like a good ounce 360
within that range but I mean back in
Minnesota I could get some gas for 240
right I mean I was buying that weed in
2000 that exact stream 2016 for 130 a
zip
fire QPS were five
hundred flat damn and then it went up to
400 because the pandemic [__]
everything up and now they're right back
down dang so weed is cheap there are the
same there's I'm gonna say the brand but
there's a cut out here of a certain dude
that charges 10 bands a pound and sells
out in seconds every [__] time in
seconds bro
and it's just a hype or is it it's good
it's it's the batches that are good or
the best OG I've ever smoked oh okay
where but the ones that I've gotten out
of 25 batches I've had four fire ass
ones and the rest I'm like are you
[__] are you serious damn the new
ones the gelatos are eleven thousand a
pound and the the price on that is so
Preposterous who I don't understand you
can't be buying the smoke you know yeah
so at that point it's like so the heady
[__] is Out Of Reach
this makes it not for I don't know it's
like going to the restaurant I go the
burgers are 40 bands I'm like
[__] Oprah that's it so Oprah could
buy those pounds
that's about all I'm trying to say guys
Oprah buys pounds
lbs all right go ahead
where you at with paranormal activities
or UFOs how is that out experiences or
thoughts on that I think I think aliens
are real because that'd be so [__]
boring if they weren't like there's no
way this whole ass Universe there's
nothing else right like that'd be insane
I don't believe that for a sec so
there's got to be something else out
there ghosts
I believe in ghosts just because it's
more fun right like I like that too
there's got to be some paranormal [__]
probably you never said I've never I've
never really had ghost experiences I've
seen I had a electronic fireplace in my
basement that turned on by itself in the
middle of the night it would randomly do
that and I was like that's either a
ghost or the electronics I [__] up
yeah one or the other yeah
but um yeah I think I was they're
probably real so nothing you ever seen
on UFO [__] out there nah nothing no I
haven't not yet
April thought we had a ghost in our
house once
my daughter was like two and she had a
big ass pile of toys and every once in a
while like you walk past the toys and
one of the toys batteries was dying on
the bottom of the pile and you just hear
like this little voice yeah from just
coming from no you can't even tell where
it was coming from every once in a while
just a little voice in two days she
thought there was a [__] ghost I kind
of did too I kind of did too
yeah that'll happen I don't [__] with
myself my older sister used to like port
and I like her but she always got
porcelain dolls we shared a room no
freaky ass dolls
ancient dolls is on the [__] shelf
like I know you're moving I know you're
gonna [__] move in the night no kid
has ever played with a porcelain doll no
you're not supposed to the porcelain
yeah
they're to look at old people to go see
my daughter likes it too like no she
[__] doesn't sister hated him but he
just got to the point where I would put
him on the ground and blank it on top of
him because I'm like yo if you move I'll
[__] know he's got a real chunky
thing too so I hated Chucky as a kid too
damn
I was terrified of the movie Jumanji as
a kid I don't even remember I made my
mom throw away the VHS I like I was that
scared were you scared because you
thought it could happen to you were you
scared yeah okay I saw something happen
in the movie and I was like no that's
gonna happen to me for sure
that was the scariest movie though I was
afraid of everything as a kid though
yeah I was a [__] until I was like 14.
oh like movies everything yeah until I
saw the movie Insidious when everything
came out oh that was over there in the
caves uh that was just like
one of the biggest horror movies of like
the past 10 years or something but it
was cool at the time it was it was
really scary but that was the the first
thing I saw and then I got like really
into horror after that
mascots I was scared of roller coasters
any mascots yeah like the people in
suits yeah like Chuck E cheese uh you
know Old Country Buffet is this
restaurant this Buffet I think it might
only be in the midwest they had this bee
I remember bawling my eyes out the first
time I saw it you were that kid we're
like yo this kid's afraid of the [__]
Mickey Mouse
I was scared I don't know uh I was
afraid of a doll that was smaller than
me so I understand his name was Chucky
so I get it and he was possessed by a
guy that he couldn't even drive yeah
it's still kind of an issue yeah no ah
after like 18 I was high as [__] with my
sister one time we were at my grandma
Grace's my dad had just bought me a
Chucky doll for Christmas when I opened
the paper it was [__] Chucky and I
just remember like the inner kid just
like [__]
everyone in my family was in on it [__]
you and uh it was [__] up and then
like a couple weeks later I remember and
the thing is my little brother Rocco my
little brother that does the comments
right now my little brother's [__] 18
now
he loved the dog so much he kept it and
I had to [__] deal with that it was
in my house damn like the doll he loved
it dude as a kid I thought it was like
put it underneath the toy test and like
put toys on it anyway we're getting high
one day my sister's like dude jump on
him
you're right I could just jump on top of
him and crush him
all right and that's the day I stopped
being afraid of Chucky I uh generalized
I mean rationalized like he's a doll
fool yeah find a gangbanger uh of course
yeah
my mom his heart in that [__] so
yeah I feel you I'm being scared of
stupid [__] yeah like mascots and Chuck
E cheese But Chuck E cheese
those [__] animatronics are scary
hell yeah you've ever seen that movie
Fright Night at Freddy's Five the game
yeah yeah have you ever seen the movie
there's a move yeah Nicholas Cage is the
star of the movie
and it's a full movie and it's so
graphic and gory bro I have not seen
that not like they're all killers right
all the mascots are killers right that's
what those the game's about yeah that's
the movie then yeah it's it's it's a
terrible movie but like Nicholas Cage
[__] shut up but you should watch it
oh hell yeah I'll watch horror movies
dude like what's the last one you
watched last horror movie
uh smile oh this is creepy look that
[__] was pretty cool it was amazing yeah
like out of like the past few years I
feel like movies in general unless
you're watching some dramatic [__] or
like superhero [__] it's the movie pool
felt kind of dead but I thought smile
was good for horror did you watch that
black phone movie yeah I know I don't
want to spoil for everybody but I
thought it was okay and then I was like
oh
I wasn't stoked yeah I remember people
in my twitch chat were hyping it up and
I saw it and I was like it's a basic
horror movie this the concept felt
familiar you know I feel you on that I
get that I don't watch a lot of horror
because I don't [__] with that [__] but
in that movie without spoiling the [__]
for people that want to watch it I'm not
gonna let a child kill me yeah it's not
it's just not I'm gonna I'm gonna flex
and bust out of that it's not gonna
happen a little boy's not gonna
manhandle kill me bro super sorry back
to Chucky back to see exactly so I was
afraid of a doll for eight pound doll
but not a 12 year old yeah so yes so yes
uh did you watch that movie parasite
yeah that [__] was sick great that was a
good movie bro yeah I think the last
movie I ever watched that was a horror
movie was a human centipede movie oh
[__] no I don't like that movie bro I
don't like that movie me and my friends
used to watch that when back when I was
scared of [__] we would watch that and I
remember just like being at the Sleep
looking down in the corner yeah looking
down or uh the last time I was at a
sleepover watch House of a Thousand
Corpses when I was like 17. I don't know
I was like 14 or something like that you
ever seen that no oh Rob Zombie movie
House of thousand corpses I have none
Devil's Rejects oh you like core movies
go watch both of those those are good
[__] horror movies that are slightly
kind of funny okay word oh yeah Rob
Zombie he's a good director with [__]
[__] dude yeah like Rob Zombie's a
[__] man I don't like horror movies
but I like that you're into that I have
homies that go to Horror Nights horror
events [__]
memorabilia [__] like uh I [__] with
toys heavy like I buy a lot of like
random toys but not horror [__] bro I
want to laugh you're getting me into
like memorabilia [__] art little pieces
and [__] yeah did you [__] with cool
anything like that toys you collect
little things I like paintings I like
savings like artwork same here dude I
had to start giving some of it away
though like I feel like I had too much
damn like there's a point where it's
like what the [__] when you move it's
like a whole load is your paintings come
on too much you just got Tony that sick
ass one right yeah so now I'm like
buying my homies like [__] like yo you
put this in your house I love art I love
that [__] I went to Art basil have you
ever heard of that yeah I went there
like a couple weeks ago in Miami damn
and it was cool bro it was like a swap
meet of art every store was an Art
Exhibit which I found pretty cool so
including glass art yeah dude there was
a whole section of Swiss perks
inside of a gallery it was pretty
Preposterous they had a like a
the guns with the stands the big ass
ones the full sit and Call of Duty the
big oh but it was a it was a dab rig
and it was fully [__] functional they
had a tree about this big branches and
everything in Vines and [__] and the and
the cap was on the top that was the
craziest smoke looked like the Avatar
tree yes it looked at the Avatar tree so
people are recognizing that glass is Art
bro and it was at Art battles it was
very cool to see that's sick that was
really cool dude um all right cool so I
know we went way off topic but let's
wrap up the uh oh that was it paranormal
my bad yeah
man where the [__] yeah all right all
right so before we get here I we asked
the fan questions we asked when it comes
to certain guests that people ask for
constantly
there's always like
this is what happened we had Goblin on
the first time and then we checked the
comments people you should ask this this
my we need to ask fan questions because
there's only so many opportunities his
first interview ever either so people
are waiting like when they see this like
oh did you ask this and this so that's
what we do now before so we asked some
fan questions and we're just gonna run
through them real quick
I think that's about it all right she
loves she loves kuya where's trip story
where I should say worst trip story
do you do mushrooms and [__] I used to
do psychedelics back in college
um I I kind of stopped I've I only
really smoke nowadays but
my worst trip story I had an acid trip
where I tried like jumping off my
balcony I don't remember it but like
apparently that happened other than that
I had one where I was coherent where
um
we got raided by the police and that was
less than twitch [__] though no no no no
this was back in college I was chilling
on the couch trying to like just lay
down take in everything all of a sudden
you're
open up it's the police I put my hands
up I'm just like well it's over I I
accept it I don't know what's coming but
it's over for me but my roommate
answered they searched us for weed or we
got snitched on they thought we were
selling and they found two grams of my
homeboys [__] he wasn't he didn't even
live there with us they just found his
[__] and took it but yeah that was that
was a crazy did a dorm room I was in an
apartment at the time damn they really
thought you guys were selling them yeah
holy [__] man you can just do that yeah
you just come and raid somebody with no
evidence it's [__] crazy
it was like a school sanctioned
apartment like oh so you're on their
time so it was yeah it was an apartment
type [__] yeah oh so yeah it was
basically like your own school property
still yeah you're [__] in the Navy
essentially get your Barrack search at
all times all right so that sounds
[__] terrible did they know you were
[__] up
I don't know maybe I was silent the
whole time they asked for my name and
they wanted to see my ID so I just said
my name and show them my ID that's it
other than that I was just silent like
staring at him trying my best to keep my
clothes yeah like that was right after
my Peak I was like oh no and then I shot
right back up when I heard the Knocks
what did you see
could you be coherent enough like this
cop turned into a [__] monster no I
wasn't that it wasn't like that intense
of a trip because it was like one tab
but
it was more just a feeling like you know
the come up feeling that constant
anxiety yeah it didn't suck it was like
that time's up I can't explain it I
can't explain it there's no way I would
have just sat there Frozen complete
silence yeah I was I thought it was over
that was [__] up but other than that I
love shrooms shrooms are a great time
I'm sorry you're a D1 athlete and you're
getting [__] up I love this I was not
the okay the night I quit track and
field I
I took acid and then I got a call from
my
um trainer they were like uh hey you're
getting drug tested at 7am tomorrow
that was another [__] up trip right
another reason I kind of stopped acid it
felt like just weird [__] always
happened when I was tripping so
um yeah I I looked at my homeboy I was
like dude I'm gonna fail this drug test
I've been smoking every single day and
he was like we could get a detox for you
so I was like okay good idea then I was
freaking out because I was like on the
come up of the trip and he was like what
do you want to do and I was like we
should smoke on it
so we just went and smoked I eventually
felt better but I pulled up for the drug
test and I took a detox before like
hoping to pass it and
my pee was too diluted at first or
whatever the [__] so they made me pee
again but I didn't have more p in me and
when you take a piss test at the U of M
or any NCAA establishment they gotta
watch the P come out like a probation
[__] oh like they stare at your dick and
I wasn't prepared for all that I didn't
know that was how it went down but
so I couldn't pee for a good two hours
we just kept going back and forth dude
look at my dick I stand there like
not yet not yet we just go back go back
like it was [__] up it's a violation
and then after that I was like my back
is messed up I'm gonna fail this drug
test
I'm already like thinking of dropping
out of school I just went up to my
trainer and said I think it's over I
think I'm done so [__] yeah that's that
piss test would keep me out of sports
bro I'm sorry no that was my that was my
second time getting tested at the uh as
you fail before no I passed oh I have no
clue how now I got caught smoking that
time so they tested me because I didn't
get caught smoking I got caught in a
room that smelled like weed but there
was also like alcohol and [__] so that
got back to my track coach and then he
had to drug test me and I passed that
one something he failed they're like you
know how fast this kid is you know how
long he can jump
he passed on some football [__] like he
got an A
yeah he has an a I'm glad to hear he has
an a yeah for real dude Sports rule
everything academics are there just like
oh it's just it's just you play football
here I think I'd be at least for me all
right cool next fan question I think we
have one more or two more if you can
make your own strain what which one
would it be and why from Phi Lavado good
question I like that My Own Strength
what's the cross
what are you doing
I don't know I like
I like [__] that got like that rotten
fruit sort of vibe I like
guavas a lot of fruit yeah like I'm
trying to like lemony fruity citrusy
sort of Terps that's pansies forbidden
fruits stuff like that and then if it
got like a little gas crossed with it
you know that's me dab I just got into
rosin when I moved downstairs
it's better than any [__] thing else
bro I like it I I still prefer a joint
over oh I'm talking about BHO butter
yeah it's just the rosin is just the way
to go when it comes to concentrates it's
wait so how's the broads in Arizona
you're gonna get taxed if you oh that's
gonna hurt you what's the gram out there
oh it ranges from like there's some like
lower tier shift for 45 but like if you
want a good gram of rosin from a
dispensary that's 80 from a dispensary
80 bucks right Black Market you could
get like 30 bucks 40 yeah for some good
[__] but that's you could do that
anywhere I feel like because I know
Arizona a lot of people out there got
fired so I'm surprised to hear that it's
like
so tags I feel like Arizona I mean it's
right here yeah that's what I'm getting
that's why I was so confused when I
first moved out there like it's right
here yeah right next door you said
you're in Phoenix yeah
the biggest [__] place isn't it so
what the hell
it's just expensive out there I don't
know weird market like they want their
[__] money do they have the uh the
tribe dispensaries out there
try like the Native American Ones Still
I don't believe your boy from Buffalo
was telling me that's how it's cracking
out there yeah Buffalo they have like
reservations where they have
dispensaries you go on there's no tax
because it's reservation land I don't
know about that yeah fat dispensers out
there about float Arizona so okay well
I'm telling you you got them out there
because I know for sure they got them
out in Arizona okay yeah yeah they'll
let you on they'll let you on and they
want your money they'll take it they
probably grow [__] fire for the past
400 years that their families lived in
that state
all right uh go ahead next one
I don't know if this is like an inside
uh question here last one we gotta
ignore Anthony how's the 200 yard roll
going
oh
um
I got a oh yeah
the Thousand meter paper yeah Oh I
thought this was some gymnastics [__] no
um
I made a tick tock a little bit ago
saying I was gonna work on smoking it
like see how fast I could finish it I
just realized how long a thousand meters
is that [__] is not getting done
anything
did you have a spool is it bigger than
this it's yeah about that big it's yeah
I'm trying to say you got about 15 years
of smoking yeah that's what I was
thinking yeah
and that's a foot and you're smoking
joints yeah it has about five of these
yeah I smoke five of these but some days
I don't smoke some days I might only
smoke one joint or whether I'm busy or
I'm out of town I'm not using that a
pack of cold I'm on the road I use it
you can't always have the spool with you
he sent me one a long time ago but it
was like a
would you wrap presents in like [__]
wrapping paper at the tube yeah and I
pulled off and she like
bro it was for pound like a half pound I
was trying to do but he gave me it
because he's like I don't have anything
like that I can [__] make it though
I'm like
I'm sorry but thank you he made it
though it was like on a wrapping paper
sheet yeah pretty [__] cool bro it's
pretty cool I use the joint glue you
ever use that yeah I have some of that
[__] Works they have a little tube you
just
many joints have been used with joint
too I mean joint glue whoever made that
as a [__] Jeep
do you think Josh made that
I'm not sure honestly I wouldn't say I
wouldn't be surprised I mean the first
time I visited him he gave me some of
that so
look did you invent joint glue probably
probably
dude okay all right on the damn how long
you how much have you done oh not that
much all right there's no glue on it
either right
I have a spool I think there is I could
be mistaken probably not because then it
would all get sticky sitting in that box
yeah oh it comes in a box yeah it's like
it's a product yeah
I think he's selling these now bro I
didn't know I had no idea that
God damn oh OG only rolls with the rolls
oh I can't I can't do it dude I had to I
need that one line of structure yeah I
prefer just using I have to have the
structure dude for some reason I'm just
I wrote Good joints but I'm just not
there
one day last one uh he actually had all
the questions oh the worst trip story oh
okay okay okay so that was the fan
questions ma'am before we get out here I
just wanted to make sure that people out
there that follow you got a few in in
the 200 yards or would you call it I
don't know a thousand meters
I think it's a thousand meters a
thousand sounds so far wait no hold up
it sounds so far 100 meters
well yards and meters the same [__] yeah
down there yeah right three feet three
feet now it's long it's it's almost got
football fields we've got 10 football
fields of weeds that's a cool way to put
it damn you guys want the football field
the joints this last month
[__] it up I just keep track of it you
should keep every time you cut some off
write it down
there you go pretty smart yeah
man smokes football field worth of weed
there's your YouTube video
there it is for real I rolled a
15-footer once out of out of 12 inches
didn't it
there was no smoke power yeah
it went across tables onto DVDs it was a
joint contest
first thing I ever tried for a joint
contest and I'm like yo I got pounds a
week I'm gonna keep rolling these
together and rolling and I rolled them
all the way to get good picture you lost
that [__] though right like you didn't
win the contest I won
but it didn't smoke no it was who could
roll the longest joint oh a lot of
people got mad
but you didn't say I guess it barely hit
bro like if I pulled
it stayed lit and you could see movement
but it wasn't like I'm like
yeah no like I could taste it okay
Vapors and that was about it you know
um okay so on all your social media it's
Chrissy doll and everything except
Instagram no Twitter it was kudala
how do you smell it C uh-u-d-a-l-l-a oh
okay so the same [__] yeah I'm burnt
I just try to spell that without I'm bad
all right so for everyone that wants to
follow you they can go follow your
Twitch that's the most important thing
to you right now that's what you're
streaming you're streaming every single
day except for Sundays Sundays what's
that day what are you doing I'll just
chill oh okay all right I was like you
know Sports guys like you don't know
it's football day I'm bored of football
so I feel you on the sports thing right
now it's just not exciting as it used to
be I guess you I guess I used to play
sports play football I didn't watch it
no more
sucks so everybody that can go follow
you on Twitch Chris udala you're there
every single day except for Sunday guys
go check it out if you're not I mean
most of our people are into twitch most
and if you're smoking and chilling and
you're just hanging out
but check it out guys I always feel like
you know you've met those people talk to
them like God I'm just hanging out with
you I got no one else to chill with
thanks that's what it's about I feel
like sort of that's my whole vibe that's
the whole point like yeah it's a lot of
people out there you'd be surprising I
just got off work
I'm gonna do nothing till tomorrow I'm
like [__]
[__] when I moved to Oregon I feel that
I'm like I know homies out there so it's
it's a different feeling when you went
to college I'm sure the first day you're
like I don't know none of you
[__] yeah you know it's a weird
feeling to to know that you have so it's
cool that you're doing every day because
now you're like a [__] homie to have
every day which is stuck which is Hella
Tight dude yeah [__] sick I hope
everything keeps going and for your for
the one thing I would take away like I
know I could sell we talked about your
parents like yeah they don't [__] with
it it'll change bro I promise you
eventually with the time and showing
like no this is what I do it'll work I
know you're like you're four but like I
said it took years for me to do the same
[__] like to show that this is not just
smoking [__] weed on camera as much
as you might want to think that's all I
do yeah which is in a sense it's what
you do but it's the business aspect of
it that you're like this is
entrepreneurship I also I smoke weed on
here yeah well I appreciate that man
yeah keep go keep going bro and I I'm
glad to see it so sick thank you Marty
thank you sir appreciate you coming on
I'm excited because I'm off excited the
fans all are yeah bro I'm excited to
post this on just a little clip on Tick
Tock but yeah you're finally Jesus it's
here because for real you know I'm just
gonna use the clip from the beginning
bro because I get it every day I just
found out how to open messages on Tick
Tock did you know that you have to
why am I telling him did you know that
you have to click certain things to get
to all messages just found that ah I've
never never been on Tick Tock messages
I'm horrible at apps they keep changing
[__] around over there and it's not just
me it's like they're making it worse
every time they change how things are
it's hard to even look at your like
notifications notifications
suggest to people to watch or what bro
like I'm in my notifications back you'll
fall all 30 of these people okay so
we're on the same [__] tip then all
right I'm confused you have no idea he
could smoke weed on Tick Tock there's no
[__] there's no routine guys just
have fun all right yeah that's about all
you could do thank you bro thank you for
doing it and from another person that's
doing
the same [__] like it's a weed world
this is what you live this is your [__]
you're streaming it's you you are your
business your whole thing that's that's
what everyone's coming for so it's not
often like I say it every time it's not
after I get to talk to people that
that's what they do only like five other
people I've ever spoke to do this so
it's cool to be able to see what your
side is and your whole different app
that I don't even
I'm [__] dumb with that [__] so it's
cool to see you're dominating I don't
think I've ever seen any other weed
person with all following let alone
Millions on an app so thank you good
[__] bro good [__] appreciate it dog
Marty thank you you're out of here man
thank you thank you so much for being
here guys this has been the dope as
usual podcast this is uh Chris udala
Marty my co-host and I'm dopa Jola have
a dope ass day oh I like
I like not getting do you usually we get
so high forget everything
I like this I like this the past two
episodes
oh yeah great your highness right up
there yeah I'm like all right I'm good
that's how I always do it because every
time we do an outro I go
that's me on stream
because I'm trying to think of did I hit
everything bro you're talking finish the
[__] sentence
oh
perfect
[Music]